[موسيقى]
من ولايه نزول صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي يا هلا بهالطله يا ميه هلا يا عبد
الرحمن اهلا بك نورنا دايما بس اليوم غير
خنجر العماني
الهوى وعماني الشكل والمظهر طبعا زي ما
انتم شايفين انا اليوم لابس زي العماني
التقليدي اول شيء عندنا الخنجر اللي هو
جزر رئيسي من الزي العماني ونتحدث عنه
اليوم اكثر المناسبات متى يلبس وتفاصيل
اكثر عندنا برده الدشداشه العمانيه وعندنا
برده العتم العتم اللي هو
العصا العماني على زميلي وليد ياخذ لقطات
لهذا العصر
في عمان همم وايضا عندنا الصناعه الفضيه
هنا مصنوعه في المحل اللي نحن فيه صناعه
يدويه ايضا الى جانب الحجر الكريم هذا
ايضا العتمه والعصه ايضا همم الرجال
العمانيون يرتدونه في مناسبات الوطنيه
والرسميه الى جانب ايضا زي ما انتم شايفين
الملابس على راسي المصر العماني هذا ايضا
حكايه اخرى وشكل جمال اخر بالالوان
والتصميم والجمال الخاص في بالزي العماني
ايضا زميلي وليد سيخذكم لقطه لهذا الخنجر
الضخم الذي هو
مشابه لخنجر دخل
موسوعه غينيس العالميه هذا الخنجر تقريبا
طوله 12 سنه
سنتي نعم هذا مش لباس على الخصر
لا لا طبعا هذا
للعرض فقط هذا محتاج
يعني شخص ضخم لانه وزنه 116 كيلو القاعده
الواحده 65 كيلو السكين داخل العشره كيلو
الفضه لحالها وزنها 17 كيلو والخشب
المستخدم تقريبا وزنه 24 كيلو طبعا للحديث
اكثر ينضم الي همم الشيخ ناصر سيف بن ناصر
الطيواني وهو من تجار الخناجر ومن صناع
الخناجر هنا في سلطنه عمان صباح الخير ابو
عماد همم طال عمرك اولا انتم متورثين هذه
المهنه من اجدادنا الى الابناء صباح النور
والسرور اول شيء ونشكركم على هذا اللقاء
وهذا الاستضافه جزاكم الله خير طبعا
بالنسبه لصناعه الخناجر عندنا في ولايه
نزوى همم احنا متوارثين هذا الصناعه منذ
زمن طويل
طبعا الخنجر العماني خنجر الاصاله فخر
والعزه لدى العمانيين
ويقتنى هذا الخنجر في ايام المناسبات
الوطنيه والافراح
والمناسبات الرسميه
الان كم نوع خنجر موجود
انواع الخناجر عندك السوري وعندك النزواني
وعندك السعيده وفي خنجر اسمه الخنجر
الباطني او الخنجر الساحلي
السعر يختلف بحسب ايش بحسب التصميم بحسب
الفضه
سعر الخنجر يختلف على حسب
الشغل حسب الفضه كميتها حسب حجم الخنجر
والتفاصيل الاخرى متى يلبس الخنجر العماني
بمناسبات
الرسميه وفي ال- همم الاعياد وفي معظم
الافراح
هذاك مصنوع من من جلد الثعبان
الحمد لله طبعا مصنوع من جلد الثعبان وهو
ذو تفاصيل طبعا
تم تحديثها همم الخنجر هذا نفس الشيء
المقبض ماله من العتم او من شجره العتم
البري في الجبل الاخضر في سلطنه عمان
الحزام اللي اللي يلبس فيه الخنجر ايضا له
انواعه واشكال طبعا
بالفضه اللي هو طبعا صناعه كل هذا صناعه
يدويه وهذه الانواع تصنع بالذاري الفضي
طبعا فيها مختلف الاشكال والالوان
طيب تقريبا يبدا من كم السعر وينتهي بكم
يعني ارخص نوع كم واغلى نوع كم بالنسبه
للخناجر عندنا اللي تستخدم لللباس في حدود
200 ريال همم الى ما شاء الله يمكن في
5000 ريال واكثر
شكرا جزيلا ابو عماد يعطيك العافيه طبعا
زي ما انتم شايفين يعني انواع خناجر عديده
لكن الجميل ان العمانيين لا زالوا متمسكين
بهذا الرمز الذي يعتبرونه رمز الرجوله
والكرامه والشهامه والشجاعه
وجزء لا يتجزا من ثقافه واصاله سلطنه عمان
وحتى سلطنه عمان يا عبد الرحمن نجحت في
ابراز هذه الصوره الثقافيه من خلال السيل
الذي ترتديه يعني لا احد يحتار عندما يرى
هذا الزي ويقول من اي بلد هذا الشخص يعني
كل العالم يعرف ان هذا الزي هذا الزي
العماني والخنجر الذي يمثل رمزا في كل
المؤسسات الدوله العلم والعمله حتى شكرا
لك الخنجر
شكرا جزيلا صباح العربيه عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]